Va fan, eller är det du som spelar in?
Ja det är jag som spelar in.
Jag tänkte att jag kom åt musen här så jag bara...
Jag fick ett meddel från en i...
Vi låter detta vara kvar i podden också.
Ringde mina kollegor, vi ska starta en podd nu.
Löste det, vi börjar spela in på måndag.
Jag ska ringa Aftonbladet sen.
Ska jag hitta på ett namn här på podden?
Det behövs det verkligen en tur att intervjua på.
Är det den bästa idéen vi har?
Det är inte en sämst orginell idé, men inte den sämsta idéen vi har.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Det är ett inledande namn.
Exakt, det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt, det kör vi på.
Det får det bli, klart.
Då går vi vidare.
Jävla bra intervju.
I alla fall, vi välkomnar Brian van der Brink in i podden.
Tjena Brian.
Tjena, tack så mycket.
Kul att vara med.
Jag tänker att många vet vem du är, men om man inte vet vem du är, kan man säga att du är det centrala mediahuset för träningsbranschen, det stora konglomeratet som bestämmer vad som ska synas och inte synas.
Ja, men ja.
Kort som er så kan man...
Lite så är det, för det finns ingen annan branschmedia.
Vi kommer ju in på det sen varför jag drog igång det här, men det var en brist som jag såg i branschen.
Att det inte fanns enkel tillgång till information om vad som hände och vad som var på gång.
Så att om någon annan gjorde det så fick jag dra igång det.
Men jag har en bakgrund här i träningsbranschen.
Jag har jobbat marknadsföring i olika roller, bland annat på SATS och på Teknogym.
Kort, summerat.
Nej, inget kort summerat.
Kan vi inte få lite, kan vi inte få en...
För nu har jag lyssnat på några poddar om dig.
Jag har ju varit på det ett par gånger om att vi ska ha ett ordentligt Brian-inlägg.
För det är du som rapporterar om alla och det är du som har koll på alla.
Men vi får liksom aldrig veta någonting om Brian.
Och när du pratar om din bakgrund så är det så, ja men jag var på SATS, ja jag var på eller du säger Teknogym, jag säger Kikraft.
Men ja okej, det betyder ju ingenting.
Kan vi inte få en liten historia om Brian's rejäla bakgrund?
Vad har du hela vägen tillbaks eller i yrket mest?
Ja nej men vi behöver inte veta vart du föddes och vad du tyckte om som treåring.
Men hur kom du in i träningsbranschen?
Jag kom in efter att jag pluggade i Örebro, på Örebro universitet läste ekonomi men valde marknadsföringskurser så det blev marknadsföring som det är min grej även om jag har en, vad fasen heter den, en titel inom ekonomi helt enkelt.
Men hur som helst, mina första jobb inom marknadsföring var på event sidan så jag jobbade för ett par olika eventbyråer och på den sista byrån som jag jobbade på så fick jag och en kollega, Norberto, som var med och drog igång så att det var businesspodden, vi var kolleger där.
Han jobbade som gruppträningsinstruktör vid sidan sitt jobb som projektledare och jag hade liksom ingen jättepelning på träningsbranschen så jag har ju spelat hockey och fotboll och haft tillgång till gymmet i ishallar och i anslutning till fotbollen och sen har vi haft gymmkort på lokala gymmen.
Men jag hade inte riktigt sett industrin bakom, hade ingen koll.
Så vi fick insatt som kund och jobbade med att öppna.
Vi tog fram ett koncept för hur de skulle öppna sina nya anläggningar med lite presale och marknadsföringskampanjer och öppningsevent för att liksom maximera medlemsantalet fram och under öppningshälgen.
Så det var det jag jobbade med.
Och sen efter drygt ett och ett halvt år då vi jobbade intensivt med kanske 20 nya gymförsats så fick jag frågan om jag ville bli anställd där som eventansvarig.
Så först blev jag uthydd där via eventbyrån och sen till slut gick jag över helt till en anställning på Sats.
Jobbade på där med event under drygt ett år och sen gjorde organisationen om lite grann så blev jag marknadsansvarig för Sverige.
Och sen sista två åren, ett och ett halvt år som jag jobbade inom Sats jobbade jag på nordisk nivå med olika marknadsföringsprojekt egentligen.
Då handlade det väldigt mycket om att få ihop Sats varumärket på samma sätt i Sverige, Norge och Finland och Danmark var det då och sen försvann Danmark och nu är Danmark tillbaka för dem.
Men då handlar det väldigt mycket om att tajta till varumärket och få en enhetlighet i det över marknaden.
Så det är det jag gjorde på Sats.
De rollen i alla fall.
Varför skryter du inte lite mer i podden?
Nej, alltså grejen är den att jag är ingen person egentligen som gillar att stå i centrum.
Men jag hamnar där av olika anledningar för att man driver på saker och gör och tvingas in det.
När vi drog igång med podden så var det Jan Norberto och han är ju mer en extrovert person, så gillar du att tjabba med alla.
För mig, jag gör det och det är kul men för mig tar det väldigt mycket energi.
Jag gillar ju att sitta på min kammare och skriva och fundera och läsa och analysera saker.
Men sen när han fick ett jobb som gjorde att han inte kunde fortsätta med podden på grund av intressekonflikt så stod jag i ett val egentligen.
Ska jag fortsätta den själv eller ska jag lägga ner den?
Relativt många lyssnare som vi hade byggt upp under åren så kändes det också lite så där, fan det här är någonting bra och det är kul.
Så jag fick ju lyfta mig själv där, shit här får jag snappa upp för att nu ska jag driva samtalen själv och äga podden.
Så och fronta den på ett annat sätt.
Men jag har också tänkt så här med Sweater Business att det ska inte handla om mig.
Det ska vara en plattform som är ett varumärkande plattform som står för sig själv.
Sen blir det ju väldigt mycket, det är ju i princip vad jag som jobbar med det numera, eller för tillfället, då blir det ju väldigt sammanknippat med mig som person, i alla fall för dem som är insyltade i branschen.
De som kanske är lite mer ytligt, som ibland surfar in på hemsidan när de lyssnar, de kanske inte har så bra koll på det.
Så att nej, det ligger inte naturligt för mig att hålla på att blåsa upp mig själv.
Jag levererar istället och visar vad skåpet ska stå.
Nu ser ju inte alla som lyssnar men du sitter och skruvar på dig samtidigt som du pratar om det självrätt.
Men du föreläser väl en hel del och är du obekväm då också?
Nej, det är jag inte nu längre.
Jag tyckte inte det var jättekul att presentera och sådär i skolan.
Tidigt i min karriärpåsats så var det väldigt mycket månadsvisa, kick-offer med säljteamen, platscheferna och träningsansvariga.
Både i Stockholm och Göteborg så två gånger i månaden var jag tvungen att presentera vad som hände på marknad, aktuella kampanjer och uppdateringar.
I Stockholm var det över 200 pers och Göteborg var det lite färre, kanske 70 pers.
Men det var ändå en del så där fick jag träna på det där.
Jag var inte bra i början och vår vd Farad som är på Keycraft, han gjorde så att ledningsgruppen fick gå en presentationskurs.
Den hjälpte mig väldigt mycket att vässa till verktygen och utmana lite själv.
Så det gäller ju att hitta sitt sätt att göra det på också.
Är man ingen Tony Robbins eller någon sån där, då ska man inte låtsas vara det för att det blir inte bra helt enkelt.
Nej det blir bara avsjukt.
Men numera är jag bekväm i det.
Kan nästan tycka att det är lättare att presentera för fler personer än för en väldigt tight grupp som ibland är när man blir inbjuden till någon ledningsgrupp eller liknande och ska prata kring marknaden.
Och så sitter fem, sex pers.
Om man sitter ganska nära blir det väldigt personligt.
Kontra sitter 200 pers på lite distans.
Man har ljus i ögonen och inte kan få den här super-connection med individer.
Jag håller helt med.
Jag jobbade som föreläsare ett tag innan detta och det var alltid så.
Är det en stor grupp?
Alla tänker att det ska vara obagligt.
Det är inte så obagligt för att drar du något skämt kommer alltid några att skratta.
Frågar du någonting kommer alltid någon att svara.
Är det fyra pers?
Då måste du typ fånga fyra pers.
Annars är det lite obehagligt i det där rummet.
Det blir trångt och det är inte så.
Ja, och så står man och analyserar också i samtidigt man presenterar hur det tas emot.
Jag vet inte hur du övade på den tiden, men det är samma som när man pitchade för de gammal flickvän eller sånt där.
Man stod framför en person och föreläste bara för att det är ingenting så obehagligt som att stå framför en person och bara snacka.
Nej, jag ger en repa aldrig i mina presentationer.
Jag har svårt att få samma tändning, för jag kommer inte att presentera det på det här sättet som när jag kör en dry run för mig själv.
Men klart jag går igenom den i skallen.
Men de säger ju att man bör gå igenom den och köra den, men jag vet inte, jag har svårt att göra det.
Okej, jag gör alltid, till och med när vi sitter här så har jag såhär, när jag sitter i bilen så går jag igenom frågorna och så typ vad du ska svara för att jag ska kunna se lite vart vi hamnar i.
Jag måste gå igenom det.
Sen behöver jag inte titta på frågor eller mina anteckningar eller sånt där, men jag måste gå igenom det.
Det är bra, som sagt, jag bearbetar uppe i skallen rätt mycket, men jag skulle säkert kunna utveckla det där ordentligt för att bli riktigt vass.
Men det är också skillnad om man är, jag har en kompis som är föreläsare på riktigt, och kör väldigt många föreläsningar.
Jag har kanske tio stycken per år och han kör 70 kanske till 100.
Så för min del är det en liten sidogrej kopplat till det jag gör, snarare än mitt yrke.
Ska vi lämna presentationsteknik?
Yes!
Så går vi in på Sweaty Business, för det är ju det du är känd för idag i alla fall.
Om du beskriver lite dels kanske hur ni startade det, för ni var väl två på den tiden, Donald and Aito som du nämner, men också hur tankeprocessen fram tills att ni startade.
För du hade ju ändå en, om man beskriver det som en intressant karriärsmöjlighet inom branschen, som du ändå hoppar av, eller du kanske också hamnar i konflikt mot dig själv på ett sätt om man ska bli journalistiskt korrekt.
Det hade varit kul att få höra lite om tankarna där bakom.
Ja, det är helt rätt.
Det är jäkligt intressant det här.
Vi drog igång det som en podd.
Jag lyssnade på poddar relativt tidigt, om jag då ser jämfört med hur utvecklingen har gått på podd.
Jag lyssnade nu på en helt annan nivå och lyssnade då rätt mycket på framgångspodden med Alexander Perler-Ors.
Och tänkte, asså det finns ju massa intressanta profiler i vår bransch, som inte är liksom framgångspoddens stora, för då var det ändå, då hade han de stora namnen och sen blev det någonting helt annat.
Jag tänkte säga det, får man säga att podden har blivit sämre.
Men det kanske inte behöver...
Jag kan ge min åsikt, du behöver inte ge den.
Nej men jag håller med och jag lyssnar ju inte på den längre.
Som sagt, i början hade han ju alla de stora, och då hade man inte heller lyssnat på...
Nu är det ju inflation för att gäster är med på många olika poddar, pratar ungefär om samma sak, så att det blir liksom inte den här unika grejen för att han var så tidigt på det.
Men jag var inspirerad av den och det formatet, en intervjupodd med spännande entreprenörer var i märken, och snackade med Norberto och vi tände ju tillsammans på idéer, så att vi bara, ja men fan vi kör.
Och Norberto hade nog inte lyssnat så mycket på podd som jag hade gjort, men jag kände också att han är en bra sidekick till mig, och vi kompletterar varandra.
Jag är lite mer kanske ordning och reda och styr ut tekniken och allting och sånt där, och han är idé spruta och liksom helt orädd, hoppa in i saker.
Så att det var så vi drog igång Sweater Business och namnet, det är det bästa namnet som finns, alltså det är ett fantastiskt namn.
Ja, det är ett grymt namn.
Nu när jag tänkte på det, jag har glömt bort hur vi kom fram till det, men jag tror att vi bara snackade svettiga affärer.
Så att combo är bra och de flesta fattar det rätt.
Förutom de som säljer och säger Sweaty Business.
Nej, det är inte godis.
Så vi drog igång och fick lära oss googla hur vi skulle göra tekniskt och utrustning.
Och det var inte så bra utrustning som fanns för att spela in själv.
Så att vi hade en kompis till Norberto som har en poddstudie där det spelas in stora produktioner, typ P3-dokumentärer på den nivån.
Så att vi lånade in oss där på Södermalm och körde våra intervjupoddar.
Det har hänt rätt mycket sedan den tiden.
För då sköt vi från höften, gick in i poddsnacket utan något...
Manus har jag inte men jag har ju ett fråge ungefär, vilket ämne eller vilka frågor det ska röra sig om.
Så att jag inte missar det.
Sen kan det ju sväva ut i lite andra grejer.
Jag vill gärna tajta till det.
Men då körde vi bara hejvilt, precis som vi tänkte och bara ställde frågor.
Hit och dit.
Nej men det fanns ju ingenting annat för branschen på den tiden.
Jag tror inte heller att influencers och liknande som har träningspoddar var igång med podd på den tiden.
Så det fanns inte så mycket.
Så den växte till sig och folk uppskattade det vi gjorde.
Och så frågade folk om olika saker.
Då hade vi ju varit i USA ganska nyligen så det var mycket butikfitness och vi pratade väldigt mycket om butikgym och olika affärsmodeller kopplat till det och så var det folk som frågade om olika koncept som vi hade pratat om.
Då väcktes tanken i med om att dra igång det som en slags blogg med ett nyhetsflöde.
Men fram till dess så hade du ingen tanke att kapitalisera på det eller?
Det var mest bara en rolig grej?
Det var en rolig grej.
Okej, jag var på Keycraft på den här tiden när vi drog igång det.
Och sen, och det här kopplar också till karriären.
Jag kände att jag hade fastnat lite.
I efterhand när jag tittar på min yrkeskarriär så, nej jag hade kanske inte fastnat.
Jag är lite otålig person sådär och gillar inte att ha rutin eller tråkigt.
Som kan vara en nackdel eller kan vara en fördel.
Men jag kände också lite såhär, vart ska jag ta mig härifrån?
Vad vill jag göra som är kul?
Sedan kände jag också, det här var 2017-2018, marknadslandskapet förändras extremt snabbt.
Många fler kanaler, mycket snabbare kanaler.
Många företag är fortfarande i det här att marknadsorganisationen hänger inte riktigt med förväntningarna på marknadsföringen.
Det känner väl du till, allt som är inne i e-handel, vilket tryck det är.
Så jag kände också, nej, jag kommer inte kunna leverera det som förväntas utan att gå under.
Vi skulle behöva dubbelt så många personer för att göra det här.
Vi hade diskussioner med Håkon och Farad, Håkon som äger Kikraft, kring det här.
Och jag fick presentera en plan där jag hade dubbelt personalstyrkan på marknad.
Och insåg att det inte är rimligt att ha en så stor marknadsorganisation här.
Samtidigt så sa jag, vi behöver göra det här.
Men om jag tittar på Kikraft idag, så är ju marknadsorganisationen någonstans där då, i den här raden av antal personer som jobbar.
Så jag var inte fel på det, men var möjligtvis tidigt på det och Kikraft var inte där.
Så jag kände att nej, det här behöver jag gå vidare från.
Och sen blev det ju faktiskt lite gnissel kring podden när den drog igång.
Jag har alltid jobbat med sociala medier på min privata del och bloggade under ett antal år också.
Jag vet inte, ett träningsblogg som jag körde.
Så jag såg det här som ett nytt uttryck, en ny kanal fast på samma spår.
Men de såg väl kanske inte helt på det sättet och tyckte att podden är någonting annat.
Så jag sa upp mig utan egentligen någon plan.
Så det var det som blev då.
Okej, vad kan jag göra med Sweaty Business då?
Men fanns det någon inkomst i Sweaty Business då eller sa du bara upp dig?
Inte med podden, nej det fanns det inte.
Så jag kände att det behövs en, då blir det från det här tänket att starta något bloggflöde, så tänkte jag okej det här behövs någon riktig hemsida där man kan erbjuda kommersiella möjligheter för annonsörer som vill synas mot den här målgruppen och gör det på riktigt.
Då fanns ju gymbusiness.se som var en liten inspiration också.
För den fanns ju för branschen men väldigt fokad på gym och kanske lite mer, jag vet inte, coachande.
Så här ska du göra, så här säljer du, så här marknadsför dig.
Det var inte det jag tänkte med, lite mer neutralt branschmedia och visa upp vad som händer i branschen snarare än att berätta hur folk ska göra.
Och Björn då som hade ju en business, hade ju en liten annan affärsidé också.
Delvis han hade ju de här kommersiella kring sajten men han hade också en konsultdel som var en stor del av det han gjorde.
Så att mycket där syftade ju också till att sälja in hans konsulttjänster.
Men sen gick ju en business in i Sweaty Business.
Eller ni gick ihop tror jag ni sa i något poddinlägg.
Men business försvann lite.
Ja nej men den försvann.
Vi körde ju på parallellt under ett par år.
Jag hade ju Sweaty Business som ett sidoprojekt under jag skulle säga två år kanske.
Två nästan tre år.
Och drev det vid sidan av diverse konsultuppdrag inom marknadsföring.
Så det var egentligen så jag försörjde mig till största delen och började bygga på med samarbetspartners kring Sweaty Business.
Efter något år pratade jag med Björn och han var sugen på att sluta upp med det han gjorde inom Gymbusiness men han ville inte att den skulle försvinna helt och hållet.
Alltså bara lägga ner det.
Då kom vi överens om att jag köper upp Gymbusiness och så jobbade vi tillsammans under ett års tid.
Under en övergångsperiod och sen efter det så eller vi släckte ju ner Gymbusiness så fort vi ingick samarbetet.
Men vi jobbade tillsammans för att det skulle bli en schysst övergång från det till det nya.
Så att det var så upplägget var och är.
Vissa tror att det var någon konflikt och så.
Ja men varför jobbar inte Björn vidare?
Nej det var aldrig tanken.
Han har andra idéer om vad han vill göra.
Så det är inga konstigheter.
Du har ju gjort två miljoner poddavsnitt.
Jag tänker att den svenska marknaden är ju inte så stor.
Du har ju haft en del internationella gäster.
Men finns det någon som du inte har fått med?
Om du tänker att den här borde jag ha fått med.
Den här längt är jag för dig.
Någon svensk?
Ja.
Det kan ju inte finnas någon kvar nästan.
Nej, jag har fått dem som svårast var faktiskt Magnus Wilhelmsson.
Att få in ens få tag på honom ordentligt och sen att få till podden.
Men sen var det inget konstighet att spela in med honom.
Vi hörs ju med jämna mellanrum i diverse frågor.
Ska vi säga till alla att det är vd för Nordic Wedness eller ägaren?
Ja, exakt.
Alla som inte är bundis med honom så att säga då.
Nej det vore väl kul att säga.
Det är väl Sondre Gravir som är koncernchef på Sats som jag frågade under pandemin.
Men det var ett lite annat fokus.
Men alla andra vd för de stora kedjorna var ju med under pandemin.
Men de hade tydligen lite mer än alla andra att göra.
Hansen skulle nog kunna vara en intressant gäst att få till längs med vägen här.
Så att det är också så här, var tar man vägen sedan då?
Visst kommer det in nytt folk som man kan intervjua.
Men jag tror också under framgångspodden att det finns ett bästföredatum för en podd också.
Så det finns ingen garanti att det här fortsätter hur länge som helst.
Kan vi inte hamna där lite grann då?
Du beskriver det också som lite rastlös.
Jag fattar grejen, jag är likadan.
Man vill säga, vad ska jag göra nu då?
Vad är nästa grej då?
Kan du inte beskriva lite, är det svartvisning som är utvecklingsgrejen eller är det någon annan grej du går och funderar på?
Ja, det är en bra fråga.
Det är grejen just nu skulle jag säga.
Jag har ingen nostalgi över saker.
Jag går vidare med prylar och kan vara stolt över saker man har gjort.
Men jag har ingen anknytning sen jättelång tid efter att jag har lämnat saker.
Sen personer och sådär, absolut.
Men själva jobbet eller företaget i sig inte så mycket.
Så jag kör på med det så länge jag tycker det är intressant och det bidrar.
Det växer fortfarande, både i följare och läsare på webben.
Och lyssnandet på podden är väl ungefär samma.
Det ligger på en stabil nivå.
Det är ingen jättepodd men det är en ganska nischad podd ändå.
Sen beror det på vilka gäster man har, så märker man ju framförallt på LinkedIn att folk hör av sig som kanske inte man känner till sådär.
Då märker man att det är gästen som de har lyssnat på som fick upp ögonen och därför halkade de in där.
Så Sweater Business idag är ju hemsida, det är podd, det är sociala medier.
Nästa logiska ben är ju event egentligen.
Om jag tittar på andra mediehus också så är det väldigt mycket event och eller utbildningar på olika sätt som de kopplar till sig.
Så jag ser att det är ganska lite branschevent som finns i Sverige och jag är på en del internationella event.
Jag är inte jätteimpad av det som är, jag tycker det är ganska låg nivå ibland jämfört med andra branscher som jag varit i och man varit på riktigt häftiga grejer.
Det blir gärna gratis event, det är gratis för deltagarna men liksom.
Man kommer dit, kör ett styrningpass, man får en mislibar och så går man hem.
Exakt, så jag tror det där också att det finns utrymme om man fyller det med lite mer värde så kan man också ta betalt för att få en en ekonomi i det också som gör det värt att göra.
Men event är rådigt, jag kommer ju från eventbranschen också, var ganska mätt på att göra event.
Jag gjorde liksom jättemånga events under flera år så att jag har varit lite så här bara aj va sen ska jag ge mig in och göra event igen.
Men nu måste jag säga att jag är sugen på att ta fram något bara för att nej men det är för svagt och de jag pratar med på marknaden tycker jag också att det är trist att det inte finns så mycket bra branscheevents längre.
Fitnesshästevalens business to business del kör de ju inte i år på grund av svagt intresse och det var egentligen dalande innan pandemin också.
Så där finns det någonting att göra.
Så där kanske det blir lite nyheter under nästa år.
Spännande.
Än i dag, jag jobbar ju lite grann med marknadsföring och hjälper några företag på en liten del av min tid.
Jag tror också att drömmen är väl att kunna foka helt på sweat to business och utveckla fler delar på den.
Men gör du inte bara sweat to business idag?
Gör du inte allt genom sweat to business?
Jo men om jag tar fram sociala mediestrategi åt något företag, så har jag bara det bolaget.
Sådana projekt kan jag vara involverad i.
Men om jag ser mig själv jobba med sweat to business om fem år, det vet jag inte faktiskt.
Det kanske är något helt annat.
Men känner du ingen bebiskänsla för sweat i business?
Att du aldrig har kunnat hoppa över till att göra ett eventsystem inom sweat i business, men kan du bara låta podden dö och nyhetsflödet dö eller är det att någon annan ska ta över det då?
Känner du att det inte har gjorts så länge?
Ja, men om jag drar igång med eventet så då är ju inte tanken att fimpa hemsidan och släppa de delarna.
Sen med podden är det så här att vi får se.
Det kanske inte är så att den kommer en ny tappning i sånt fall, men liksom ett nytt upplägg som gör det intressant.
Eller ett mixat upplägg med intervjuer.
Jag hade ju med Norberto ett format som heter Sweaty Business Trends där vi snackade lite mer subjektivt och fritt kring olika saker som hände som var väldigt uppskattat och avsnitten står sig starkt i det totala lyssnandet.
Så det finns ju någonting där.
Men då ska man också hitta antingen någon som man kan teama på det eller har också en tanke att man kanske skulle bjuda in olika personer i de här trendavsnitten och prata om olika saker.
Så det är ju ett sätt att fräscha upp det och hålla det vid liv.
Men som sagt, livslängden för en podd som kör kanske samma format, den tror jag ändå är begränsad över tid.
Om man inte är typ Filip och Fredrik eller de här mastodontpoddarna som har så mycket lyssnare så att det kommer rulla på oavsett.
Ja, jag håller helt med.
Det är ganska få poddar man lyssnar på som man har lyssnat över många, många år.
Det känns ofta som att nu börjar den här dala.
Nu blir gästerna tråkare och tråkare.
Ofta upplever vi att presentatören tar över, och ofta mer och mer och börjar prata om sig själv.
Det skiter väl jag i, jag lyssnar ju på gästen.
Nu är du fortfarande väldigt bra på det, du säger ju ingenting om dig själv.
Det är ju därför vi är tvungna att ha dig här.
Ja, men grejen är att jag lyssnar mycket på podd, dels för att hålla mig uppdaterad om olika saker, men också för att omvärldsbevaka vad som händer inom poddmediet.
Vad gör duktiga poddskapare för att hålla sina poddar vid liv?
Men en sak som jag verkligen är allergisk mot är just det du beskriver att presentatören poddvärlden sätter sig själv i centrum.
Jag har lyssnat på en podd som jag nu har fimpat, Tutto Balutto, fotbollspodd, Thomas och Gusten, och har se in bra fram till en viss punkt när de blev så...
För de har blivit stjärnor under tiden, så de är större än sina gäster.
Och man får den känslan också.
Ibland när de svarar, man ser på sociala medier hur de dissar folk som...
Alltså om man är en offentlig person får man ju ta lite dissar.
It comes with a price.
Folk kommer och dissar dig, men du behöver inte ge dig in och kalla folk väldigt fula saker.
Som ett små barn.
Så där känner jag att nu är ni konceptet.
Ni är Philip och Fredrik inom det här.
Och era gäster kommer nästan in och tackar för att vara med.
Och så är det superintressanta gäster som man vill höra deras stories, för de får stora namn som man inte har hört så mycket i poddar, liksom i fotbollsvärlden.
Om det då blir, ja, jag har spelat fotboll i division 6 i Florens.
Det är helt ointresserat, Tomas, av din division 6 fotboll.
Nu har du Markus Allbeck här, han ska berätta om tiden när jag ståndvilla.
Det är det jag vill höra.
Du kan inte ens sätta dem i samma rum.
Det är pinsamt att ta upp sin egen så kallade fotbollskarriär.
Så det är jag allergisk mot.
Ja, jag förstår.
Får du mycket, jag tänker att eftersom du ändå är det enda, jag vet inte vad ordet är, jag kan inte säga branschorganet, för det finns ju givetvis en massa branschorgan och grejer i branschen, men det finns ju inte så mycket seriösa outlets för folk som vill synas i vår bransch eller som ska hinna i detta.
Hur mycket påtryckningar får du att vara med i podden?
Dels att vara med i podden, men också lägga upp de här nyheterna.
Har du sett våra nya serie här?
Det är en ny sorts.
Jag tänker hur mycket är rena nyheter och hur mycket är tryckt reklam från sidan som du tvingar stackarna i till och med att det blir okej, här går gränsen typ.
Hur gör du avvägningen där?
Avvägningen, det kommer en del förfrågningar, men det kom väldigt mycket i början att folk ville in och började tog för givet att man kunde få gratis spridning av allting och sen har jag hållit en viss spår.
Det där är ganska lite nu.
Det är podden när det är en hel del som hör av sig som vill vara med, men då är det ofta kopplat till ett om någon produkt eller de är aktuella med någonting.
Och då är det så här, ett rent produktavsnitt är inte jätteintressant, det måste vara lite större kring det.
Så jag har väl gjort några avsnitt som jag bara kände såhär, det blev inte svinbra sådär.
Så det är en avhängning man får göra.
Men folk är inte så på, och det är märkligt för jag har rätt mycket kompisar som jobbar i helt andra branscher och trycket som är på att få företag att synas och ta plats är enormt.
Men jag tycker faktiskt att folk är ganska, typ så här, poddmediet.
Du får en dryg timma rätt in i någons öra, full attention, ett par tusen per avsnitt.
Det har varit ganska svårt att sälja in poddannonsering.
Jag har inte tryckt på det jättemycket, men jag som lyssnar mycket på podd är så här, ja, hittar man relevant om man har ringat in målgruppen och hittat ett bra sätt att komma in i podden utan att störa för mycket, så det är ett skitbra sätt att se in oss och höra.
Men det är också så här, branschen är ganska omogen, trots sina 30-40 år på nacken som en professionell bransch och så finns det en hel del hemmasnickreri i den här branschen som jag fortfarande inte fattar varför man inte kommer vidare ifrån.
Det är ett område som jag vill snacka med dig.
Du ser ju branschen från sidan samt som du är i branschen och det är rätt kul att du har hela den här marknad-
och eventbakgrunden som ju träning är egentligen perfekt för.
Den här branschen ska ju egentligen drivas.
Det är klart den inte måste drivas på det sättet, men jag menar att den lämpar sig så väl för att drivas med lite glamour och lite puffo-piffo-puffo.
Det ska hända grejer.
Absolut.
Men det är ju som du säger, ibland relativt tråkigt.
Kan du inte ge din take lite på tränningsbranschen?
Nej men det är liksom, det är en liten sån här berg-och-dahl-bana, det är både heaven och hell ska jag säga, men det är liksom högt och lågt.
Passionen, det som fick mig är liksom wow, här vill jag jobba.
Det var ju som att träffade folket på sats när vi jobbade med events.
Det var så jäkla välkomnande, energifyllda, att alla som är i den här branschen känner till att folk i allmänhet är väldigt positiva och energifyllda och pensionerade för det de pysslar med.
Det var alltid från telekom till köpcentrum till försäkringar, det var duktiga yrkespersoner men kände jag att de brann för.
Menar du att passionen inom telekommarknadsföring inte var lika hård som träningen?
Det är svårt att tänka sig.
Så det kände jag också bara shit, det här kan man ju kombinera på deras interesse.
Men det är väl också kanske förbannelsen, att folk är faktiskt beredda att jobba med sin passion och då ge avkall på mycket annat som är hygien i många andra fall, ordentliga anställningsformer, ordning och reda, på papprorna, ordentligt utbildningsprogram.
Mycket i den här branschen bygger fortfarande på att PT själv ska signa upp på olika utbildningar och kompetensutveckla sig.
Men om jag tar mitt marknadsföringsyrke, så fick jag såklart förhandla till mig olika utbildningar och ibland så fanns det en bra plan för det.
Men gick jag en kurs på Bergis, inom något område som är Bergis School of Communication, då visste jag också att det här innebär att jag är mer attraktiv i nästa skede och också en anledning att bumpa upp lönen vid nästa förhandling.
Att man nu har fått den här kompetensen.
Men det är ju svårt i träningsbranschen.
Om du är en person i gruppträningsinstitut går du ytterligare utbildning.
Det syns inte på ditt lönekuver heller.
Så att incitamenten att utbilda sig och ta nästa steg för många som är på golvet, som är och träffar kunderna, är ju sådär.
Jag är personligen ganska orolig för kompetensnivån generellt sett.
Vi var väldigt högt, upplever jag, och ansedda internationellt sett.
Sedan ser jag hur många andra länder springer fram och lite mer ordning att reda kring licenser och utbildningsnivåer och vilken nivå på utbildningar.
Medan vi har gått åt ett helt annat tal, om man tittar till exempel på petutbildningar, mot att stora bulken utbildas online och väldigt korta utbildningar.
Så där finns det en matchningsproblem, att konsumenten uppskattar att behöva spendera lite tid, så lite tid som möjligt i utbildning och spendera så lite pengar som möjligt.
Dels kan sitta hemifrån och göra det parallellt med något jobb och inte behöva resa in och spendera tid i en fysisk sal.
Medan själva yrket oftast är ett hantverksyrke.
Du måste ju träna och gnugga på dina skills.
Du ska kommunicera och prata med människor.
Det är en helt annan sak att göra via en skärm kontra att träffa en människa live.
Se saker, träna upp sitt öga.
Du har ju också varit PT, det är väldigt mycket.
Det tar ju lång tid innan man blir riktigt bra på yrket.
Det är ju paradoxen också.
Då tappar vi väldigt många PT.
När de har två, tre år och börjar bli vassa, då börjar de plugga eller få barn och så inser man att det blir svårt att vara där tidig morgon, kväll, helg.
Vilket är konstigt.
För de flesta andra yrkena så vill det ju ha kvar de som har högst kompetens, såklart.
Det känns också som en lågmarginal bransch generellt sett.
Om man tar gymmen då att vissa gör liksom pengar, men många är ju ganska lågvinstmarginal, om någon alls.
Det är ju ett ämne som du har pratat om ganska mycket i podden, det här att folk inte vågar ta betalt som driver gymm.
Eller kanske överlag ska vi säga om hälsotjänster.
Och det är ett problem, blir ju ett problem, för då kan du inte investera på samma sätt.
Du kan inte investera i personal.
Så det blir ju en ond spiral.
Jag vet inte i fasen man löser, men det finns ju vissa som har knäckt koden.
Fittnes 24-7 som gör skitbra resultat.
Är vi dömda till en lågmarginal?
Nej, det är vi fasen inte.
Men det gäller ju att snäppa upp sig där.
Och jag vet inte, branschen har ju växt konstant egentligen.
Och sen, vad kan man säga, nu kanske de senaste fyra, fem åren så börjar man väl kanske nå någon slags mognadsfas.
Att okej, nu blir det väldigt crowded på många ställen.
Så det räcker inte med att ha fräsa lokaler, senaste utrustning, för alla mer eller mindre har senaste utrustningen.
Och kunderna i slutändan har ju inte så stor koll på vad det är för grejer de tränar på.
Det är ju hardcore-tränande som har väldigt bra pailing på vad det är för grejer de tränar på.
Men gemene man, som ändå är den stora målgruppen för de kommersiella gymmen, de vet ju inte vilket löpande de springer på.
Och har ju väl ingen anledning att veta det heller.
Det är väl för att de inte har givits någon anledning att tänka på det.
Ja, man behöver ju hitta olika sätt att konkurrera på och sticka ut i mängden sådär och kanske också bli bättre på att kapitalisera på de mängder av medlemmar som ändå finns där.
Mer försäljning, andra produkter.
Finns det några profiler eller några gymm som du har exempel på som du tycker gör det jäkligt bra?
Det är ju ofta i, tycker jag, mindre städer.
Nu bor jag i den största staden i Sverige så allt relativt blir mindre.
Men de lokala gymmen på orten, jag kan säga, Form Gotland tycker jag är skitduktiga, liksom, som jag är på på somrarna.
Jag får ju säga, Barrys här i stan, det är ju ett koncept, liksom franchise-koncept, men de är ju väldigt, väldigt duktiga och har, vad jag förstår, också en ganska stor del av sina intäkter från shop och sin bar, med Shakes och Smoothies, och är duktiga på att baka in dig i bokningsprocessen, där du redan där kan boka in din Smoothie, och den dras på ditt kort, som redan är uppkopplat till ditt medlemskap, så du behöver aldrig stå där och bara ha med med kortet, ta med med mobilen.
Alla de här trösklarna är borta och förenkla.
Så det är väl sådana.
Sen finns det ju massor av gäng.
Umeåsport och motion har jag inte varit på, men av det jag ser och det jag hör verkar jag väldigt duktig.
Så det finns ju antal därute.
Men kedjedriften, de är ju duktiga på liksom mata ut många anläggningar, men det är ju ganska generiskt sådär, det är inte så kul.
När kommer Sweaty Business poddserien som tar topp tre inom varje område, sig gym, PT, influencer, cost, etc.
Och så gör du en serie med dem där, vad är det de gör riktigt bra som alla andra, de kanske inte vill vara med och berätta vad de gör bra.
Men säg som en sån här grej där man bakar in smoothies.
För jag har också drivit ett gym ihop med några andra och det var också ett sådant lite high end gym.
Där ville vi också sälja mer grejer, men vi tänkte aldrig på att det är klart att man ska ha med det i bokningen.
Det är ju skitsmart, det är klart att när du bokar passet ska du klicka i om du vill ha tillbehör.
Varför tänker vi inte på det?
Det är en jättesimpel idé.
Det finns ju massa sådana smarta, små knep och trix.
Den serien vill jag ha.
Absolut, det är en superbra idé.
Jag tror ändå de flesta är ganska bjussiga i branschen och skulle säkert ställa upp och snacka om det.
Så att, mm, absolut.
Det finns ju en podd, How I Built It eller någonting sånt där.
Jag vet att de har lyssnat på den.
Han heter något sånt.
Jag lyssnade på den när jag var, när den äldsta sonen nu inte kunde somna på kvällarna så gick jag med barnvagn fram och tillbaka, då lyssnade jag alltid på den podden.
Jag tror den heter How I Built This.
Det är ju ett intressant koncept.
Nu går jag igenom hur fan har du tänkt?
Det tangerar ju det här.
Absolut, det skulle kunna vara intressant.
Det är också min ambition att blanda upp de stora drakarna med lokala, lite mer nischade eller mindre aktörer så att det blir en spridning på vilka som är med.
På något sätt så kommer ju den stora massan, den kommer ju inte bli ett Nordic Wellness eller Friskis och Sweppis eller något sådant där, utan man vill ju ha en livsstil där man kan försörja sig på det, försörja sig gott på det och sen kanske börja lämna över till någon som tar över alla adminter.
Absolut.
Och då är det ju dem, den sortens anläggningar eller PT-kollektiv eller vad vi ska kalla det.
Det har varit spännande att höra.
Som sagt, branschen, det är högt och lågt.
Jag tycker den rör sig snabbare och snabbare mot en professionalisering, ytterligare både här lokalt i Sverige men sen mycket ut i Europa.
Och det är väl sista tio åren, fem, tio åren, kommit in mycket folk utifrån från helt andra branscher som tar med sig bra grejer därifrån.
Allting går ju inte att applicera men som också lyfter att sätta lite perspektiv.
Jag tror att det är bra att det kommer in och mixas upp med de här som är födda och uppväxta i branschen och kan kombinera de där två tillsammans och kan lyfta till nya nivåer och också göra det som en möjlig karriärväg för fler och därmed också kunna locka till sig skarpa människor som vill vara kvar i branschen.
För en spaning är väl att även om branschen på ett sätt kan synas som att den är trendig så är den ju otroligt trög.
Vi som säljer gymutrustning är det ju väldigt tydligt, det är ju så här, här kommer nyhet.
Fast det var ju egentligen inte nyhet, det var ju en ny färg och en skistång.
Hur spännande är det egentligen, det är fortfarande en skistång.
Slappna av nu, så spännande var det inte.
Det är samma sak med gym, det är klart att man byter utbud, men det är ju ganska liknande.
Absolut, det är det.
Det är som du säger, det är inte några stora innovationer som sker snabbt.
Det kommer någonting då och då, men det mesta är en förlängning på något som redan finns, eller en variant på det.
Hur många gånger har du haft diskussionen med gäster, hur ska man få PT-verksamhet lönsamt?
Det är en fråga som har uppstått ett par gånger.
Det är en fråga som har uppstått, och framförallt off-mic, att folk vill diskutera det.
Det verkar vara väldigt knixigt för företag därutom att få det där att funka, konstigt nog.
Om vi tar träningsbranschen, känner du, är du fortfarande väldigt passionerad för tränningsbranschen?
Eller är du mer passionerad för nyhetsrapportering i sig, eller utvecklingen i sig?
Nej men passionen för branschen finns där.
Sen, i och med att det här har blivit mer mitt yrke, någon slags hybridjournalistpåverkare, så är det ju mycket det, att försöka bli bättre och vässa mig inom de delarna.
Sen är mitt fält träningsbranschen, men samtidigt skulle jag tycka att det var lika roligt att göra det här i någon annan bransch.
Nej, det hade jag förmodligen inte tyckt.
Så det är ju såklart intresset och passionen för branschen.
Men kanske inte lika som när vi drog igång det.
Men det kanske också är mer insyltade i allting om man ser baksidorna utav vissa delar och sådär.
Man är en del och jag är också rädd för att vara, bli en del av etablissemanget eller att bli, jag vill ha lite distans och inte bli såhär, jag vet inte, jag gillar ju att kunna ha halva benet in och ändå kunna stå lite utanför.
Men jag inser också att ju längre tiden går ju mer drasiga in liksom.
Har du ångest för den dagen någon säger, ja men du vet Brian, ja, det är så jävla standade, det är han som jag förstår.
Nej, det skulle vara jättetråkigt om det skulle vara en tråkig plattform om man liksom ingrudd, inpydd och fastnat i samma hjulspår.
Så absolut, det är en delrättsläpp som jag har.
Och där vill jag inte hamna.
Har du några konkreta, du nämnde ju det här med väntebenet som som är en potentiell utvecklingsgrej, men har du haft några konkreta projekt genom åren som du ändå har varit sugen på i branschen, som du känner att det här saknas, eller det här borde någon dra igång eller?
Ja, nej men jag var ju med och startade en PT-skola, Human Performance, som fortfarande finns kvar och numera är del ägd utav STC Trading Club.
Och det var drivet rätt mycket av den här utvecklingen mot de här kortare PT-utbildningarna som både jag och Erik Börgeson, som fortfarande är kvar i bolaget, såg och tyckte att det var en dålig utveckling.
Samtidigt så tyckte vi att många av de traditionella PT-utbildningarna hade stagnerat.
Nyss som jobbat med samma gamla material och samma sätt att utbilda på.
Och sen skulle vår nisch också vara lite mer vidare utbildningar, som det inte finns sådär jättemycket av i Sverige.
Det är ju liksom kostrådgivning, det är mamma-gravid typ om man hårdrar det.
Och Erik hade varit på rätt mycket grejer, workshops och grejer i USA och i Europa, så tanken var väl att dra hem den typen av personer hit och köra, plus skapa egna vidareutbildningar.
Men vi drog igång någon månad innan pandemin slog till, så kickade vi igång bolaget och hela planen.
Så det blev ju en jäkligt konstig start på det.
Även om vi liksom fick ganska bra traction, hyfsat omgående, så var det ju väldigt mycket med pandemin om sig och kring sig, och flyttat till digitalt, pausa, utbildningar, folk blev rädda för att träffas, och det var liksom adminhelvete.
Och sen började pandemin klinga av, och då var det typ två, för jag var med två år, två och ett halvt där.
Men jag kände att jag tappade energin för det projektet.
Jag hade tatt väldigt mycket energi utav mig.
Och sen ville vi lite olika också med att vi ville skapa.
Jag kände att om vi skulle göra den här grejen, så vill jag att det ska bli ett ordentligt bolag.
Och det tar lite för mycket tid för att vara ett litet side hustle.
Sådär.
Jag ser inte att Erik inte vill att det ska bli ett ordentligt bolag, men han är också en person som har mycket grejer för sig.
Så jag såg inte riktigt med vårt upplägg.
Jag hade svårt i business, han hade under en period heltidsanställning och innebande coach i högsta innebandeligan, pappatränare för barnens dag.
Alltså hur många timmar finns det på dygnet?
Så då inledde vi diskussioner och han ville fortsätta med det, så då hade vi dialogen ett drygt halvår, hur vi skulle göra och vilket upplägg.
Vi skulle göra och hitta det framtidens lösning som var okej ändå.
Vi blev inte mångmiljonär, men rik på ändå erfarenheter som jag tar med mig och mycket lärdomar framförallt kring entreprenörskap och sådär som jag tar med mig framåt.
Kan du känna dig låst i att om du ser en brist i tränningsbranschen och du känner att det här skulle jag vilja hoppa in i, säg som en PT-utbildning då.
Du är ändå på något sätt beroende av sponsorer eller drag i sweated business.
Kan du känna att du blir konkurrent till din egen brödsöda?
Ja men det är ju absolut en risk som man kan hamna i och som man alltid får fundera kring olika saker som man gör.
Vi är allt syns och hörs.
Vi kan också ta ett konkret exempel på något som är helt legit på sweated business-plattform.
Alla annonsörer och samarbetspartners kan ju välja att trycka på, satsa mycket och då var det ett av företagen som under en period körde rätt hårt på en viss produktserie och marknadsförde.
Då kom det en kritik från andra partners som tyckte att de fick väldigt mycket utrymme.
Och sen vet jag vissa kunder till andra annonsörer som hade kanske en konkurrerande produktserie i sin rum.
De frågade sina leverantörer, ja men varför syns inte era produktserie lika mycket?
Så sitter man där så är det så att man bara, men det här är helt öppet, ni kan ju, ni kan också köra på och gasa på marknadsföra era produkter.
Så man hamnar i de här grejerna tidsomtätt.
Och det kan också vara mellan gymmen och gymmskedjorna.
Om den ena syns så blir det ett raise, att då vill någon annan synas eller ifrågasätta, ja men det där var väl ingen nyhet eller liksom, det där känns uppblåst.
Det är så här, jag lägger mig inte i det, jag kommer inte lägga upp bluffnyheter, men om någon anser att de har en framgång med någonting och vill puffa ut det, då lägger jag ut det.
Om det inte är hittepå så kommer ju den, då är det en nyhet, absolut.
Sen kan någon annan tycka att det inte är en nyhet eller ingen stor grej, så det får någon annan avgöra.
Så man sitter i dem där.
Spelet är ju vad spelet är på något sätt.
Ja, så det är absolut något man får ta hänsyn till men samtidigt ska jag inte vara låst till vad folk tycker och tänker och säger.
Och det är väl min devis här, om man undrar över någonting, hör av er och ställ frågan, så finns det förmodligen ett bra svar på det.
Eller så har man gjort ett misstag och då får man bara backa på det eller säga att det blev fel på ett annat sätt.
Men folk kan vara rätt dåliga på att fråga.
I stället går man och tänker att det är på ett visst sätt men man har ju ingen aning.
Exakt.
Man surar lite i smyken.
Jag älskar det, jag har hänt det några gånger.
Ja men det har hänt så att det är herregud så att man får...
Absolut, jag hatar.
Jag tänkte, vi har ju fått rätt mycket information, det är kul, men vi har ändå träffat sjukt många människor i branschen inom olika områden, allt från liksom...
Ni hade ju en intervjun här med EC Design, som är rätt nischat för...
Ja men vi använde ju EC Design till exempel, upp till som du sa Magnus Willemsson, som är ju Nordic Wellne som alla känner till.
Men om man vill försörja sig i branschen, om man vill in i träningsbranschen och faktiskt göra det här till sitt liv, som många vill varje år, sen är det ju extremt många som bara faller undant att det är väldigt svårt att försörja sig i branschen.
Finns det någon sorts generell tips eller om du delar in i kategorier?
Hur ska man göra för att leva i den här branschen?
Ja, om jag bara tittar tillbaks och funderar på alla entreprenörer som jag har träffat i podden och i olika sammanhang så slår det mig tidigt att de är multiconstnärer.
Många har haft flera karriärer i branschen.
Man kanske har börjat med en grej och sedan hoppat vidare till nånting annat och sedan skaffat sig olika kompetenser.
Så jag tror att man ska ha ett ganska öppet sinne på PT-utbildningar och sådär.
Jag är dels på human performance, det jag själv utbildade inom framförallt marknadsföring och försäljning.
Så pratade jag mycket om att ha flera ben att stå på.
Dels är det affärsmässigt att det kan vara smart att ha inte bara PT one-to-one som sitt försörjning, utan att tänka gruppträning, tänka small group, och sen är online coaching och annat kommit till, att man har en viss bredd eller kanske företags gig.
Så dels ekonomiskt som en affärsstrategi, men också för hjärnans skull, att det är lätt att bli mätt och trött.
Många kommer ju in för att de älskar träning i branschen, och sen är det såhär att du älskar träning, att du ska hjälpa någon annan som kanske inte älskar träning, som du fan nästan får tjata ner, som inte har samma driv.
Alltså det kanske inte är lika roligt då.
Så du ska ju gilla människor och jag tycker att man ska ha lite olika ben att stå på, så man är lite flexibel där för att hålla i längden.
Tyvärr så ser vi inte jättemånga P-T som går i pension i branschen.
Fortfarande en ung bransch, vi kanske får de första pensionärerna inom ett tag men folk försvinner.
Första partitetspensionären kanske.
Ja, jag tänker såhär, jag menar sjukgymnaster och napprapater.
Inbillar mig ändå att de har längre karriärer inom sina yrken än vad många genomsnittspeten har.
Och ska jag vara helt ärlig så tror jag att genomsnittspeten är nere på skrämmande låga nivåer.
Vi snackar inte ens liksom halvåret.
Nej, det känns som det är extremt roliga.
Så ja, tyvärr så blir det, om man tar PT så blir det för många kanske ett jobb som man gör när man är ung och hungrig och liksom har den livsstilen och väldigt mycket tid och kan vara väldigt flexibel men försvinner ur det sen.
Vad ska jag säga, karriärvägar, annars, ja du, det är svårt att säga.
Nu finns det ju mycket mer möjligheter än vad det fanns när jag började i branschen.
Sådär men det är ju inte så om man tänker så här kontorsjobb, backoffice, så är det ju snåligt, det är många som vill in.
Det är väl liksom en smart väg att ha varit i branschen på att som gruppträningshistoriör eller liknande så att man har någon slags anknytning eller en väg in upp på de positionerna också.
Ja, jag tänker det är samma sak inom, det finns ju otaliga gym som har startats och har lagt ner.
Det fanns ju en boom här när alla startade kosttillskott.
Vi dog ju ut rätt mycket under pandemin, hade vi ju mängder av konkurrenter inom gymutrustning.
Det sålde ju väldigt bra till hemmagym och de också stängde ner snabbt sen.
Ja, vad ska man säga, halveringstiden i våran bransch är ju, vad jag tänker, hur man ska få, hur folk ska kunna stanna lite längre.
Kanske inte är så.
Nej, jag vet inte men jag tror också såhär, många behöver göra sin läxa bättre innan.
Det som är enkelt att dra igång, tror jag också att tändera att ha en risk att vara mycket, större sannolikhet att det inte blir bra.
Alltså trösklarna in, jag tar till exempel Crossfit, som Jan Norbert var inne på, samband med att vi drog igång Svart i Business och hade tanken på att dra igång en Crossfit också.
Du kan ta lokaler som inte behöver vara mitt i stan, mycket billigare och det kan vara lite mer ruff och utrustningen är inte så dyr.
Men där har många också hamnat i fällan att det är svårt att skala upp en Crossfit box.
Det kräver mycket manntimmar, det är klasser och sådär.
Därför försvann det väldigt mycket boxar och sen har det blivit kvar.
Men det är många boxägare som gör annat också.
Jag fick en typisk case i en mindre stad som jag fick höra nyligen.
En kille som hade dragit igång en Crossfit box och investerat i bra utrustning.
Man har heltidsjobb med någonting annat, har ingen plan för försäljning, marknadsföring.
Det sätter han sig med när boxarna öppnat och inser att det inte står rader med folk som bara helt plötsligt dyker upp.
Då blir det så här, men vänta nu, vad har gått snett här på den här vägen?
Ja, så visst vill man bränna sina pengar på ingenting så varsågod.
Men jag tror att där finns det rätt mycket läxor att göra, att bilda sin uppfattning innan man drar igång någonting.
Jag tror att det är en sjukt bra punkt.
Man behöver verkligen tänka igenom.
Ja, vi ser det också, det är ju många som köper en PT-box till hemmet, det är många som startar ett litet gym och det är väldigt tydligt att man inte har tänkt igenom hur ska jag få in kunder, hur ska jag få detta att flyga på riktigt.
Utan man är så driven av den här passionen som finns i tränningspanschen att man kommer igång, tröskeln är väldigt låg och sen själv dör det ganska fort.
Det är en bra punkt.
Det var ju deppigt men deppigt men bra att avsluta med.
Nej men det är bättre att ha tråkigt innan, om man säger så, att göra det tråkiga jobbet och jobba igenom det ännu har tråkigt sen med banker och leasingbolag och grejer och ska reda upp en jävla härva i efterhand.
Sen finns det inga garantier men jag tror att många kan göra sin hemläxa bättre innan.
Jag tror att vi känner oss ganska klara där, Brian.
Jag är väldigt tacksam för att du ville ställa upp och vara med här.
Det ger ju oss lite seriositet.
Annars är det ju bara, jag hade ju tänkt åtta avsnitt med lagerkillarna där vi pratar packteknik.
Men det hade nog varit en kioskvältare.
Ja, det är våra flickvänner som lyssnar.
Jag tycker det är jättebra.
Jag tycker att allt som kan bidra till sprida kunskap och en community, samarbete i branschen, man lär sig av varandra.
Visst, man är konkurrenter och sådär.
Du var ju med i den här podden förra året och jag vet ett par av dina konkurrenter som lyssnade på det och tyckte att det var ett intressant avsnitt.
Jag har faktiskt varit iväg och haft möten med flera av de konkurrenterna bara för att de hörde av sig och var såhär att det var kul.
Kan vi inte bara snacka?
Och det är ändå, jag behöver inte ta alla namn och sådant, men det är ju företag som omsätter det tydligt mer än oss.
Så kom hit och bara snacka med våra Sweden managers och country.
Det är skitkul att bara sitta och spalda.
Exakt, och där finns det mycket.
Oavsett om det är en stor kedja, jag tror inte att stora kedjorna har att lära av enskilda aktörer som gör vissa delar riktigt bra.
Och vice versa, att de mindre kan lära sig av driftsmodell och efter vi ser fin slipning av de större.
Så apropå er podd, allt som kan bidra till att man utbyter tankar och erfarenheter tror jag lyfter branschen som helhet.
Så att fler som bidrar på olika sätt är bara positivt tycker jag.
Jag håller helt med.
Jag säger tack så mycket Brian.
Stort tack!